bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
les chauffeurs routiers européens
veulent obtenir une harmonisation de
l'entente travail ils ont dressé des
barrages filtrants dans plusieurs pays
de l'union européenne dont la france
congrès des hlm à marseille les
organisations de locataires conteste un
accord passé entre l'état et les hlm
concernant les loyers multiplication des
critiques contre l'organisation du
procès des 138 personnes accusées de
soutenir les terroristes islamistes dans
un gymnase à fleury mérogis et puis la
sortie du film de roger planchon
consacrée au peintre toulouse lautrec
les chauffeurs routiers européens ont
fait une grève aujourd'hui qui fera
peut-être date
ensemble les camionneurs de plusieurs
pays de l'union européenne ont manifesté
par des barrages filtrants placés aux
frontières les chauffeurs de poids
lourds sont exclus des lois européennes
de 93 sur l'aménagement du temps de
travail en raison de la spécificité de
leur profession il souhaite donc que
soit harmonisé leurs différentes
conditions notamment en terme d'heures
de travail de sécurité de temps de repos
et de protection sociale c'était les
raisons de cette multiplication de
barrages dont voici quelques aspects
commentaires eric midi une vingtaine de
barrages des distributions de tracts
ce n'était pas une démonstration de
force mais plutôt une action symbolique
à dix jours de la réunion entre la
commission européenne et le patronat les
chauffeurs routiers ont donc décidé de
faire entendre leur voix
on peut arriver à la trouver des
conducteurs qui font un autre choix
cette heure les 90 heures par semaine ça
le rouble parce que c'est un facteur de
danger c'est un facteur de morts sur les
routes par seulement pour la profession
mais aussi pour tous les objets on qu'on
dit ça suffit il faut harmoniser de
manière à obtenir une réglementation qui
soient respectées et appliquées par toi
harmonisation car en termes de
législation sociale l'europe des
transports est une mosaïque les
chauffeurs néerlandais que leurs
homologues français ont rencontrés à la
frontière sont parmi les mieux lotis
onze mille francs de salaire moyen et
des entreprises de grande taille ultra
compétitive qui gèrent leurs flottes de
camions par satellite
sur le pont de l'europe à strasbourg les
chauffeurs allemands et français étaient
côte à côte pour expliquer leurs
revendications la situation dans les
deux pays est très comparable avec une
durée moyenne de travail de 56 heures
par semaine
les français et les allemands sont les
bons élèves de l'europe mais faute de
contrôles suffisants
les abus sont encore trop nombreux côté
rémunération le chauffeur français se
situe derrière son collègue d'outre-rhin
entre huit et dix mille francs par mois
au barrage de biriatou au pays basque
les routiers espagnols sont venus en
renfort ici en espagne comme dans tout
le sud de l'europe
95% des chauffeurs sont propriétaires de
leurs camions
ce sont ces petits patrons qui roulent
le plus longtemps pour les tarifs les
plus bas et chauffeurs routiers présents
aujourd'hui sur les barrages attend donc
avec impatience la réduction à 48 heures
par semaine de leur temps de travail
mais ils savent aussi que le plus dur
sera de la faire respecter
alors l'un des barrages importante cette
journée une manifestation des routiers
se trouvait venait de voir oph
frontaliers franco-espagnole de biriatou
dans les pyrénées atlantiques sur
l'autoroute a63 pour bien préciser les
différences de condition sociale entre
pays nous avons choisi de comparer deux
entreprises en france et en espagne deux
sociétés de transport ou le sort des
chauffeurs n'est pas le même mais où la
concurrence à 6pts distance est très
forte
reportage juliette beau pascal golomer
et jean francois monier ce chauffeur
espagnol est installé à irun tout près
de la frontière française
il le sait il gagne moins que ses
voisins en moyenne 20%
il travaille cinq heures de plus par
semaine pourtant ses collègues et lui ne
se considère pas du tout comme les plus
à plaindre en europe
de grosses différences par exemple avec
un chauffeur portugais où un chauffeur
turc
ils sont beaucoup plus pauvres que nous
on les paye moins je pense que c'est une
question d'économie
la question économique
autre grosse différence avec les
français les périodes d'attentes
elles sont comptabilisés comme temps de
travail en france ici en espagne on ne
rémunère que le temps passé au volant
lucho los carayos halak est respecté à
l'euro près visto ce week end
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de là
de l'autre côté de la frontière une
entreprise française
malgré l'ouverture totale du marché
européen le 1er juillet dernier
on ne craint pas ici une invasion des
camions espagnols qu'à leurs sociétés
sont bien plus petit et moins bien
structuré qu'en france une structure
artisanale le plus souvent en revanche
elles sont plus rentables avec un prix
de revient au kilomètre de 4 francs
contre cinq francs 20 en france mais
vous savez si vous avez un camion qui
peut effectuer 16 mille kilomètres par
mois avec un chauffeur payé comme un
chanteur français qui en fait que 12000
ou en 2000
la différence se voit tout de suite à la
fin du mois mais pas plus que les
charges sociales à nos sponsors moins
cher et que les charges sociales
françaises d'environ 10%
l'harmonisation européenne les salariés
chauffeur la réclame pour l'amélioration
de leurs conditions de travail
les chefs d'entreprise l'attendent pour
une concurrence plus équilibrée et en
fin de journée les syndicats de routiers
estimer avoir rempli leur objectif en
france ils ont été reçus cet après midi
par le mît des transports jean claude
gayssot et à l'issue de cet entretien
les quatre syndicats cgt fo cfdt fncr se
sont dits satisfaits
les propos du ministre à moscou ce mardi
plusieurs hypothèses politiques ont été
évoqués au lendemain du refus par les
députés de la douma la chambre basse du
parlement russe d'investir victor
tchernomirdine comme premier ministre on
semble même douter que le président
eltsine
ainsi si une troisième fois comme il en
a le droit auprès des députés
langil rabin ce soir on a l'impression
que vous êtes vivre une journée de dupes
tout à fait et ce soir il n'y a plus de
candidats on est en manque de candidats
vous savez on pensait avoir enfin trouvé
l'homme introuvable le sauveur qui
allait réconcilier tout le monde
et voilà que ce sauveur il est vrai dit
primakov de mise car étrangères refuse
poliment de devenir premier ministre
alors ce soir c'est le grand vide
bien sûr il reste des candidats capables
d'obtenir l'investiture de la douma
comme par exemple le président du sénat
où le maire de moscou
mais on doute beaucoup qu'il soit encore
en mesure d'affronter et surtout de
maîtriser la crise économique
alors ce soir à moscou on parle de quoi
de la destitution dit alcine la
dissolution de la douma eh bien on parle
des deux vous savez depuis
pratiquement le début de son 200e de sa
présidence boris eltsine est menacée par
la douma d'une procédure en destitution
or si demain les députés décidé de
lancer enfin cette procédure est bien
cela aurait pour effet immédiat
d'empêcher boris elstine de dissoudre la
douma pour les deux mois qui viennent
ils se retrouveraient sans moyens de
pression sur l'assemblée et ne pourrait
donc plus leur imposer à poser aux
députés sa volonté
merci gilles et ce qui montre le plus
leur détermination à renverser le chef
de l'état ce sont les dirigeants
communistes avec à leur tête
guennadi ziouganov il croit que le
moment est venu qu'il pourrait ainsi à
la faveur d'élections revenir au pouvoir
reportage à moscou dorothée olliéric
france brille c'est la douma bien avant
cette crise politico financières les
russes l'appelait déjà ndour d'hommes la
maison des fous leur et communistes sont
les bolchéviques les léninistes les
staliniens
les marxistes parce qu'ils ont construit
le grand état des ouvriers des paysans
l'union soviétique et on est en train de
reconstruire cet état l'un à l'intérieur
de la douma l'atmosphère est moins
passionné
parmi les 161 députés communistes du
parlement quelques uns complotent
beaucoup arpentent les couloirs d'autres
réécrivent l'histoire de la révolution
de 1917
c'est la nouvelle rédaction de cette
révolution les forces essentielles ce
sont la classe ouvrière et elle est
plaisant collectivités et les
intelligents commune
il veut dire bien sûr les intellectuels
communistes
alexandre cravate c'est l'un d'eux il
est chargé de l'idéologie du parti
officiellement cette réunion est secrète
mais il nous révèle qu'il prépare des
grèves planche sur la destitution
delsinne et envisage même les pires
scénarios au président un président a
perdu la plus l'armée avec lui le peuple
est en grande majorité contre borut six
ans il est si on en vient aux armes
comme en 93 on aura cette fois toutes
les chances de gagner
trois bureaux plus loin chez les jeunes
communistes est ce que toi tu ira
défendre la douma ça tourne mal non plus
il ira sûrement pas défendre là demain
lire à casser les kiosques oui ça y est
anti mettre derrière les blagues et les
rires se cache l'inquiétude des jeunes
communistes les comme sont molles comme
on les appelle toujours il parle de la
pauvreté du peuple celle qui mène
toujours aux révolutions en république
démocratique du congo on compte les
morts dans la zone de kalemie et dans le
sud est du pays 42 tués ce week-end dans
l'affrontement entre soldats et rebelles
et puis au zimbabwe à victoria falls où
plusieurs chefs d'état africains
tentaient depuis hier de mettre un terme
au conflit
les prémices d'un accord de
cessez-le-feu ont été vite démentie les
rebelles ont fait savoir qu'ils ne se
sentaient pas engagé par l'accord signé
par laurent désiré kabila mais accords
signés 100e au cambodge monsieur hansen
l'un des deux premiers ministres celui
qui est officiellement vainqueur des
dernières élections ne supporte pas que
l'on remette en cause les résultats
depuis plusieurs jours il doit affronter
des manifestations ceux qui protestent
dénonce la triche aux élections mais
récolte au minimum de vigoureux coup de
bâton comment terrain de consignes est
ce matin où une scène l'homme fort du
cambodge a décidé qu'il fallait en finir
même violemment en finir avec ces
manifestants qui depuis deux semaines
occupait toute une place devant
l'assemblée nationale
il y avait installé un campement de
toile baptisé place de la démocratie
pour contester les élections de juillet
dernier une scène y était arrivée en
tête mais pas suffisamment pour
gouverner seul
il doit faire alliance avec ses deux
adversaires le prince norodom ranariddh
houssam raincy ancien ministre des
finances
mais pour eux les élections ont été
truquées ils ne veulent entendre parler
d'aucune coalition c'est l'impasse hier
déjà la tension était montée d'un cran
sa main si ces réfugiés à l'onu accusées
par houssen d'avoir organisé un attentat
contre lui et dans la soirée les
manifestants venus soutenir l'opposante
été dispersés par des tirs d'armes
automatiques
officiellement des tirs en l'air et une
personnes au moins et menthe
pourtant le 24 septembre prochain toutes
les partie cambodgienne doivent se
retrouver à l'assemblée nationale pour
trouver le moyen de gouverner le pays
en irlande du nord l'ira véritable un
groupe dissident catholique responsables
de l'attentât d'omagh où 29 personnes
ont trouvé la mort le 15 au dernier a
décrété un cessez le feu complet
l'ira véritable est toujours cependant
hostile aux accords de paix en irlande
au canada au large du port de paix disco
dans la province canadienne de la
nouvelle écosse les recherches des
débris de l'avion de la compagnie
swissair abîmé en mer mercredi dernier
ont été ralenties par le mauvais temps
à terre les experts tentent d'analyser
le contenu de la première boîte noire
récupérer ce boîtier qui enregistre
conversation et détails techniques de
tous les mouvements d'un avion pour
tenter de comprendre comment travaille
actuellement les experts canadiens voici
à l'aide des services de la direction
générale de l'aviation civile française
quelques explications commentaire
patrice pelé dans la boîte noire
retrouvée dimanche
il manque les sites dernières minutes de
vol c'est pendant la descente pour une
raison encore inconnue cas 3000 m toutes
les données techniques ont cessé d'être
enregistrées
dommage mais tout n'est pas perdu car un
avion c'est en fait deux boîtes noires
la première d'entre elles est un gros
magnétophone sur cette table on voit si
un semblable à celui de l'avion suisse
et il enregistre par quatre canaux le
micro du commandant du micro du copilote
le micro d'ambiance donc micro qui se
trouve au centre du poste de pilotage et
enfin donc la liaison interphonie entre
la cabine passagers
la cabine de pilotage voici la bande
enregistreuse son boîtier l'isolent
d'une température de 2000 degrés ensuite
direction le laboratoire où la bande va
être lu ici pour s'applique à rendre
compréhensibles les mots les sons sorti
du cockpit
à défaut de voir humaine on peut
entendre la dernière alarme avant akhras
le deuxième boîtier contient les données
techniques à l'intérieur jusqu'à 600
paramètres expliquent la situation de
l'avion chacun d'entre eux est
décortiqué nous avons visualisé certain
nombre de paramètres importants comme la
vitesse si rouge qui parle par exemple
de 200 ne jusqu'à l'arrêt complet le cap
qui évolue comme vous pouvez le voir
jusqu'à l'arrêt complet pour finir les
informations des deux boîtiers sont
mélangés elles permettent de
reconstituer l'histoire d'un crash celui
ci date d'il ya trois ans pour élucider
l'accident de la semaine dernière les
canadiens possèdent le même matériel
informatique que les france à l'hôpital
du val de grâce les médecins chargés du
miz l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
se refuse toujours à un pronostic et à
d'éventuelles appréciation sur les
séquelles de son accident opératoire
monsieur chevénement serait sorti de la
phase de choc proprement dite le
fonctionnement du foie et des reins
serait en amélioration c'est désormais
sur les conditions de l'anesthésique que
se portent les questions il faut savoir
que l'on est passé de 3,8 millions
d'anesthésié en france sans que la
mortalité et progresser la procédure
d'anesthésié plus sûres
notamment parce que l'on a rendu
obligatoire une consultation préalable
la france est le seul pays à pratiquer
ainsi reportage daniel flaysakier pascal
couillaud pour que tout se passe bien
ici il faut en passer absolument par
l'ase l'anesthésique commence en fait
plus de 24 heures avant l'opération
cette consultation obligatoire permet de
dépister divers problèmes et en
particulier les allergiques vous aviez
un antécédents d'allergie dans votre dos
est bien d'accord c'était de
manifestations allergiques à quel type
de produits
mais est-ce que vous avez des
manifestations allergiques d'autre
nature comme de l'asthme de l'urticaire
des francs non pelées et pour le médecin
tous ces renseignements vont guider les
choix ultérieurs 14 lui c'est parfait
parmi les différents fait l'arsenal de
drogue qu'on à la disposition on connaît
ceux qui sont plus ou moins allergisants
et en fonction de ça on va faire le
choix en fait d'organes esthétiquement
allergisantes sur la un terrain
allergique est avérée on al'occasion
déjà de bon c'est sûr c'est pas vraiment
faire connaissance mais quand même
quelque part et pendant ces différents
fin les deux ou trois jours qui suivent
ont mûri tout ça intérieurement et
finalement se prépare plus et mieux à
l'intervention qu'on aura qui aura lieu
quelques mètres plus loin cette jeune
femme va être opéré de la vésicule
biliaire pour l'endormir un médecin et
un infirmier spécialisé il dernier coup
d'oeil au dossier anesthésique a priori
ou qu'une panne aucune précaution
particulière à prendre l'an tout cas
pour cette anesthésie qui va être pour
nous pour endormir la patiente un
somnifère
un produit à base de morphine un autre à
base de curare sur les écrans rythme
cardiaque pression artérielle fréquence
respiratoire gaz carbonique expiré sont
surveillés de près dans les premières
minutes
si tu veux des produits des gens on
assisterait à des modifications sur tous
ces paramètres vitaux d'ailleurs en cas
de problème à côté des nst zik
il y a les antidotes en vingt ans le
nombre d'années stasi a triplé en france
alors que le nombre de décès n'a pas
bougé cette sécurité accrue est due aux
consultations au matériel et aux salles
de réveil rendu obligatoire le risque
zéro n'existera jamais mais si toutes
les règles sont suivies les futurs
opérait peuvent dormir sur leurs deux
oreilles
à marseille ouverture du 59ème congrès
de l'union nationale des fédérations
d'organismes hlm
en marge de ce congrès d'une bataille
pour la présidence des hlm mais dès ce
matin les quatre principales
organisations de locataires ont contesté
un accord passé entre l'état et les hlm
sur un nouveau conventionnement des
loyers autre sujet de débat les
quittances trop élevé tant dans la
colonne loyer que dans celle des charges
alors voici un exemple à cannes où l'on
a construit des logements moins chers
mais avec ça paraît tout simple moins
deux mètres carrés reportage en paix
dieu et jocelyn air muzio construction
de qualité situés en centre ville
cet hlm répond apparemment au critt et a
souhaité ces dernières années pour le
logement social
l'ennui c'est le loyer 3000 francs par
exemple pour un deux pièces
mais il ya les paliers les couloirs trop
l'eau le salon anguleux un balco
surdimensionné beaucoup de mètres carrés
inutiles qui conduisent à des logements
coûteux trop coûteux pour les locataires
modestes vu le loyer que nous arrivons à
payer au fil des années nous pensons
qu'on arrive au très facilement à des
loyers dans le privé elle au niveau donc
accès en temps d'économiser sur le coût
de construction des logements sociaux
c'est l'objet de cette réunion de
travail à l'office hlm de cannes
direction technique services de gestion
de l'office et architectes traque les
mètres carrés superflu cherchent à
utiliser l'espace au maximum on va
probablement arriver à réduire la
surface totale l'appartement d'environ
cinq mètres carrés 5 6 mètres carrés
tout en un appartement qui lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on le vit apparaît faire une
surface cette règle du mètre carré 100%
rentable et appliquée à tous les
nouveaux logements hlm résultats des
loyers 10% moins cher soit une économie
comme ici de 300 francs par mois
réduire les charges locatives qui comme
ici pour l'entretien des canalisations
sont répercutées sur les locataires
c'est l'objectif de l'office qui a
renégocié en ce sens les contrats avec
les entreprises
tous les locataires logements anciens et
neufs
sont concernés les travaux de plomberie
par exemple sont assurés en urgence
moyennant un forfait annuel de 100
francs par locataires grâce à la baisse
de la tva sur les travaux l'an prochain
les organismes hlm économiseront un
milliard de francs une économie qui sera
répercuté sur la quittance des
locataires le gouvernement renonce à
privatiser tout de suite le crédit
foncier de france ce matin mis sur
l'économie a fait savoir qu'ils
mettaient fin discussions engagées avec
un consortium américain seul candidat à
la reprise de cet établissement
spécialisé dans le crédit immobilier
hier les synthés le syndicat national
des enseignants du second degré
reportait son mot d'ordre de grève lancé
pour le jeudi 10 septembre dans lévis et
aux îles lau reporté au 24 septembre à
l'issue d'une rencontre avec le ministre
claude allaire et puis aujourd'hui
cependant le snes fsu a maintenu son
appel à la grève pour le 10 septembre
mais dans les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles
et puis le syndicat national des lycées
et collèges a également maintenu son
préavis de grève ce même jour 10
septembre dans les lycées très vive
polémique à propos du procès du réseau
dit chalabi c'est à dire celui du procès
de 138 personnes accusées d'avoir
soutenu des terroristes islamistes
algériens
ce procès se tient dans un gymnase de
l'administration pénitentiaire aménagé
en face de la maison d'arrêt de fleury
mérogis
plusieurs procédures contre je cite là
les avocats de la défense une justice
d'exception ont été engagés et 54
personnalités magistrats intellectuels
et politiques dont madame danielle
mitterrand ont signé une pétition contre
ce qu'ils appellent un procès menaces ou
les principes de notre état de droit ne
sont pas respectées reportage dominique
verdeilhan christophe airaud où sont
passés les 138 prévenu les 90 avocats
les 60 journalistes dans un gymnase
interdit aux caméras les magistrats se
sentent un peu seuls
face à eux une dizaine de prévenus
seulement résultat les audiences tourner
court
au bout de deux heures la séance est
levée la majorité des avocats a choisi
de bouder ce procès pourtant certains
ont fait le choix d'être présent je suis
extrêmement critique sur le fait qu'on
organisait un procès de masse je suis
fait contre je pense que ça ne se
justifiait pas dans cette affaire
néanmois le dossier là aujourd'hui
l'afer est audiencée les prévenus sont
convoqués
je pense que il faut être là néanmoins
pour assister un client qui a besoin de
son avocat qui souhaite que son avocat
soit là une justice d'abattage c'est ce
que dénoncent dans une pétition 54
personnalités parmi elles danielle
mitterrand léon schwartzenberg l'abbé
pierre andré téchiné et noël mamère
je pense que le jugement et la
condamnation sera d'autant plus
exemplaire que le procès aura été
exemplaire or là nous assistons quand
même à une justice qui me rappelle le
19e siècle ne nous sommes pas l'époque
d'edmond dantès signe de ce malaise
général ce matin des avocats ont été
reçus par elisabeth guigou question à
l'ordre du jour comment insisté
sérieusement un prévenus dans un procès
fleuve
comment peuvent-ils le faire lorsqu'il y
à 50000 quant à lire et 6 en trois pages
dans un vieux réquisitoire deux
solutions ou bien renvoyer ce procès ou
bien d'y joindre
et dire que telles et telles personnes
seront jugées plus tard l'absence des
prévenus et des avocats n'empêche en
rien la poursuite du procès avocat et
tribunal reste ce soir sur leur position
côté chancellerie on se refuse à tout
commentaire
on n'oublie pas en tout cas que ce
procès a déjà coûté 10 millions de
francs à toulon un substitut du
procureur de la république deux
capitaines de renseignements généraux de
marseille et un journaliste ont été mis
en examen pour violation du secret de
l'instruction
c'est surtout la personnalité du
magistrat monsieur albert lévy qui
retient l'attention se substitue qui
fait l'objet d'un contrôle judiciaire
avait manifesté sa différence lors de l'
enquête sur l'assassinât de yann piat
le syndicat de la magistrature a dénoncé
les moyens coercitifs utilisé contre
monsieur albert lévy reportage valérie
ermite andré y sera
albert lévy substitut du procureur de
toulouse d'habitude c'est lui qui envoie
chercher les délinquants au petit matin
mais dimanche dernier c'est à son
domicile que les gendarmes ont sommé six
heures de garde à vue avec au bout du
compte une mise en examen pour violation
du secret de l'instruction
albert lévy est soupçonné d'avoir fourni
une pièce d'instruction à un journaliste
un claude ardid dans une affaire visant
la mairie front national de toulon de
plus le substitut se voit interdire
l'accès de son palais de justice
il est en sommes au chômage technique
c'est un magistrat atypique dans la
mesure où ils se trouvent dans une
région atypique et c'est vrai qu'il est
en charge au parquet de toulon de tous
les dossiers et dieu sait s'il y en a
dans le midi de la france de trafic
d'influencé de mafia ii bon hélas il y
en a effectivement beaucoup et c'est
vrai qu'il s'est attiré un certain
nombre d'inimitiés on n'est pas tombé
par hasard sur albert lévy pour un
prétendu dossier de violation secret de
l'instruction
albert lévy a depuis longtemps fait
parler de lui à toulouse 2 par les
dossiers sensibles qu'ils gèrent mais
aussi après sa déposition dans le procès
yann piat il avait en substance réitéré
ses doutes quant à la volonté de la
justice de faire toute la vérité dans
cette affaire
cette espèce de mise à l'écart
professionnels qui intervient à
l'occasion d'une procédure somme toute
banale nous paraît quand même
extrêmement inquiétante dans son
contrôle judiciaire
albert lévy a aussi l'obligation de se
soigner selon son avocat on estimerait
que ce magistrat n'a pas tous ses
esprits car je cite il voit des
fascistes partout à toulon à lyon à
partir de jeudi jusqu'au 29 septembre se
tiendra le festival de danse en europe
la biennale de lyon
mais pour l'instant on ne retient guère
le programme culturel et l'on n'évoque
plus les aléas économiques de cette
biennale suite au débat politique
régionale le conseil régional présidé
par monsieur charles millon n'a pas voté
la totalité du budget nécessaire à la
biennale de lyon le front national
jouant les arbitres au sein de ce
conseil reportage eric lemasson philippe
l'oms d'ordinaire la biennale de la
danse et comme le rhône en septembre
c'est-à-dire tranquille cette année pour
la 8e édition
les apparences sont tranquilles l'opéra
de lyon s'apprête en sous sol une troupe
est en répétition les concepts qu'ils
sont maniés avec élégance
jusque là tout va bien d'autant qu'en
coulisses le lourd budget de 20 millions
de francs a été bouclée sans difficulté
non ce qui pose problème est un peu à
l'écart
loin du centre mais au coeur du terrain
politique
il s'agit du défilé d'ouverture de la
biennale
un rassemblement populaire de troupe
créée pour l'occasion notamment dans les
banlieues de la ville
thème choisi le métissage des cultures
méditerranéennes
l'ambition de la biennale et de faire
danser la ville toute la ville tous les
horizons qui sont l'état son épouse sont
tous au travail
on sent qu il yal en mouvement d'une
activité professionnelle ou devons
simplement il en coûte bien sûr quelques
deniers supplémentaires à la biennale et
c'est là qu'entre en scène le front
national dont les élus au conseil
régional refuse de voter toute
subvention à ce défilé qui valorise la
colonisation de peuplement que subit
notre pays sous le nom d' immigration
faits sont les mots de leur communiqué
impossible alors pour charles millon
privé des voix fn qui lui permettent de
diriger la région d'allouer les quatre
cent mille francs prévus il me faudrait
un appui ponctuel des socialistes
mais le ps refuse depuis le 20 mars je
suis millions est élu avec les voix du
front national le front national est le
maître du jeu et nous n'entendons pas
venir au secours de monsieur millon
front national défend ses conceptions
depuis toujours
ça n'a rien pour étonner ce qui est
étonnant c'est de voir les socialistes
se joindre au front national pour voter
ce type de pour refuser stipule fadi
mais ils disent que c'est justement pour
vous mettre face à vos alliances avec le
front national quand même la politique
du pire est la pire des politiques
actuellement par leurs attitudes sont en
train de bloquer un certain nombre de
dossiers
et voilà comment cet homme le directeur
artistique de la biennale de la danse se
retrouve cette année sans trop savoir
sur quel pied danser nous a mis dans une
situation d'otage en fait donc nous
sommes dans une situation qui est
impossible
il est évident que si la situation
actuelle qui devait perdurer dans la
région rhône alpes ce serait extrêmement
grave pour l'avenir et pas seulement
pour nous pas pour seulement pour le
défilé pour la maison de la danse de
lyon mais grave pour toute la politique
culturelle grave pour toute la politique
de la ville
mediterranea le thème de la biennale et
consensuelle tant qu'ils restent sur la
scène de l'opéra mais danser dans les
rues est infiniment plus difficile
dans la sphère du financement occulte
présumé de l'ex parti républicain deux
anciens membres de cabinet de monsieur
edouard balladur dont son ancien
directeur de cabinet monsieur bazire
lorsque monsieur balladur était premier
ministre ont été convoqués comme témoins
chez le juge eva joly
la juge d'instruction s'interroge sur
l'origine de 5 millions de francs
déposés dans une banque italienne pour
garantir un prêt au parti républicain et
puis les avocats du président du conseil
constitutionnel monsieur roland dumas
mis en examen dans le cadre du dossier
elf ont déposé une demande de non lieu
auprès des juges
eva joly et laurence vichnievsky les
avocats de monsieur dumas affirme que
les juges n'ont apporté aucune preuve
des faits pour lesquels l'ancien
ministre affaires étrangères est
poursuivi l'installation ce matin à
paris d'un groupe de travail intitulé
médecin du sport et lutte contre le
dopage avec notamment le professeur jean
paul escande
ce groupe de travail s'intéressera non
seulement au sport de haut niveau mais
aussi aux rapports entre la médecine et
le sport nous avons besoin de beaucoup
plus travaillé sur les gosses voilà
c'était madame marie george buffet et à
ses côtés le secrétaire d'état bernard
kouchner
et puis à noter que ce soir la
commission de conciliation du comité
national olympique français a rejeté la
demande du footballeur du havre cyrille
pouget suspendu pour dopage six mois
ferme et douze mois avec sursis au tour
d'espagne cycliste la vuelta
les réactions ont été vives aujourd'hui
après la publication dans le journal
france soir
deux procès verbaux mettant en cause
l'équipe espagnole on s'est emmené par
laurent jalabert celui qui serait à
l'origine de la polémique par ses aveux
le suisse alex ou le set expliqué
commentaires laurent frédéric bollée
aujourd'hui laurent jalabert a perdu
trois choses d'abord l'étape du jour de
la vuelta la quatrième ensuite il a
perdu le maillot amarillo de leader
qu'il avait endossé pourtant tiers enfin
plus embêtant laurent jalabert a perdu
une partie de ces mères
le français a très mal pris des
déclarations du suisse alex du leu hier
en effet france soir a publié les procès
verbaux des auditions des coureurs
testing as pendant le tour de france vu
le il met en cause son ancienne équipe
là on sait celle de jalabert il ne faut
pas croire que certains font toutes les
fautes et les autres aucune moi ou un
autre je sais ce qu'est le p o
mais ces révélations c'est de la merde
je me demande pourquoi tout sort
aujourd'hui au début du tour d'espagne
où l'équipe par qui le scandale arrive
une nouvelle fois les procès verbaux
représente une terrible accusation du
milieu du cyclisme
la réaction ne s'est pas fait attendre
et notamment bien sûr chez les ondes
c'est moi j'ai la conscience tranquille
l'affairé dans les mains de nos avocats
6e a fait ces déclarations sous pression
j'en suis persuadé et maintenant il y à
des fuites dans les journaux français
mais je vous le dis personne n'aura la
peau de l'ours et pour conclure laurent
jalabert prétend que c'est sa parole
contre celle des autres et que l'union
cycliste internationale et de toute
façon je cite une dictature oui à
grenade
aujourd'hui on a sorti les missions et
puis côté sport tennis aux
internationaux des états-unis à l' us
open de new york
il n'y a plus de française en
compétition mary pierce nathalie tauziat
ont été éliminés notamment par la
suissesse par l'américaine mattingly et
puis d'autre part la compétition s'est
sérieusement perturbé par le mauvais
temps
si dès ma sortie demain du film réalisé
par roger planchon consacrée au peintre
toulouse lautrec c'est toute la belle
époque le french cancan le moulin rouge
et le cabaret d'aristide bruant qui
revivent dans ce film où roger planchon
a souhaité que la légende lautrec soient
dépassées que l'on re découvre l'homme
reportage orge bégoux jean louis goût
serre on le saurait oublier albi et les
rives du tarn dans une biographie de
lautrec
quito pied de la cathédrale sainte
cécile et y vécut jusqu'à l'âge adulte
qu'est ce c'est quoi pour toi
vous voulez des mioches qu'ils soient
des monstres comme votre au nabot tu
n'es jamais éternelle henry ne le
devient pas la vie est un don de dieu la
vie
je n'y comprends rien enfin tous et
simplifie quand je fais un dessin le
château de la berbie près de la
cathédrale conserve le plus d'un millier
d'oeuvres une prodigieuse donation de la
famille la comtesse a dans un premier
temps souhaité proposer au musée
parisien
ces musées ont refusé le don est donc la
comtesse à proposer l'ensemble de ses
oeuvres à la ville d'albi on sait ce qui
se passe dans les ateliers tels que al
r&b se retrouve avec un hameau dans le
tyran qui réclament déjà n'est pas à 100
il semblerait que toutes les femmes qui
ont rencontré autre que l'on aimé alors
évidemment il faut savoir que c'était un
liberta il faut savoir qu'il avait un
contact sexuel qui fréquentaient les
bordels chez toi
tout ça est vrai dans les bordels on
l'appelait la cafetière à un
porte-manteau donc ça dit tout ce que ça
veut dire que les couacs excuse pour toi
qu'on aime pas trop sérieuses et les
deux fois c'est un homme qui est
profondément d'une violence totale dans
ses peintures mais qui dans la vie est
plutôt accommodante
ce qui m'a aussi beaucoup surpris c'est
par exemple qu'il n'ait jamais rompu
avec sa famille
c'est ça s'est pas passé comme ça c'est
pas l'image du peintre maudit tu prends
ta mère comme une reine en exil
c'est une reine nds
ds i was la piétinent et l'oriental
roger planchon oubliant un peu le
théâtre se révèle un cinéaste
d'envergure il filme avec virtuosité
l'incontournable morceau de bravoure de
la vie de lautrec
le french cancan
oui
l'autre est dodue planchon sortie demain
en chine à pékin un évènement musical
inédit avec la représentation de tueur
en doc l'opéra inachevé de puccini c'est
dans le décor authentique de la cité
interdite de pékin là où l'auteur avait
cité son oeuvre que ce spectacle
grandiose a eu lieu pendant trois heures
une production de 15 millions de dollars
qui devait attirer surtout déterminée
touristes étrangers reportage à pékin de
nos correspondants isabelle bechler et
tristan le braz on a beau être soldats
de l'armée populaire de libération
il faut passer par les fourches caudines
du maquillage quand on est figurant dans
la superproduction de tueur en dot à la
cité interdite et la jugulaire d'époque
mines donne parfois quelques soucis
une heure avant le début du spectacle et
le prince calaf et ses dernières
vocalises avec la servante liot pour
jour son suicide pour un magazine
chinois avant de poser avec 6,8 métal
chef qui a rendu possible ce tueur en
dotant décoré m pour cet événement
culturel rarissime des amateurs d'opéra
sont venus du monde entier
en cette soirée de gala les occidentaux
avaient dépensé plusieurs milliers de
francs pour les meilleures places
c'est mon cadeau d'anniversaire pour mes
80 ans ce voyage enfin surtout nos
perdre
vous avez une idée du prix se sont
intégrés laissez moi vous dire
franchement
quarante deux mille francs pour fin juin
malgré les prix exorbitants champagne et
petits fours étaient payants mais parmi
ces dames certaines n'auraient jamais
connu la chine ceinture en dorthe
nous connaissons tous plus ou moins con
mais la chine rouge jusqu'à l'ouverture
fut grandiose à la mesure de
l'architecturé de 500 ans d'âge de la
cité interdite
la profusion de soieries des costumes
scrupuleusement brodé selon l'époque a
ébloui les spectateurs
l'écrin était magnifique pour monter en
épingle la cruauté de la princesse tueur
en dot puccini fut bien servi moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé il y a des gens qui sont
inquiet pour l'intégrité du mal à mort
historique et la salle est interdite
je ne sais pas mais la musique les
décors sont superbes
le décor est vraiment magnifique
comme l'action se déroule dans l'endroit
thing cela mérite vraiment d'être vu
johnny moss fait un superbe travail de
mise en scène les neuf représentations
d'exception ne feront pas le plein
déplacer plus cher ce sont les droits
télévisés qui renfloueront la production
un projet peut être un peu trop
ambitieux et qui aura laissé de côté
le gros du public chinois
voilà pour finir ce journal je vous
rappelle deux informations nous avons
développé dans cette édition tout
d'abord la grève des routiers européens
elle tente d'obtenir l'harmonisation
notamment de leurs conditions de travail
et puis le procès chalabi pétition et
polémiques les avocats qui ne veulent
pas continuer à ce procès ainsi dans ce
gymnase de fleury mérogis pour la météo
dans quelques instants c'est nathalie
rihouet à 20h50 le film de cédric
klapisch
chacun cherche son chat et puis à 0
heure quarante de retrouver bruno
roger-petit à 7h50 demain françoise
laborde dans les 4 vérités motoroi
michel barnier président du conseil
régional de savoir à 13h carole gaessler
et rachid arhab bien sûr à demain 20h
bonsoir merci